[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God the
Is
>> that his angels are responsible for his
welfare and wellbeing? Give me the
verse. And where did he say he'll take
that form?
>> Say the devil
right here.
>> Where does he say the devil tormented
him?
>> This dude right here in the verse where
it says the devil tormented him and beat
him.
>> I've been watching you. Your sanity is
doubtful. So let me talk to you. He's
running.
I'm here in front of you where the devil
needs
everybody. We need some space here. All
right.
>> So everybody create some room.
>> Look just one second my brother. We try
to set this up. So guys, we need the
space so that our debaters can debate
with room and you guys can see things
and the camera can catch everything.
Okay, so you guys are good. Can you guys
all hear me?
>> Let me hear you say Jesus is God if you
can hear me.
>> All right, cool. All right, that's good.
So
>> we need a mic.
>> So we're all good here.
>> IRL.
>> Yeah, we got He said, "Yo, do we need
help?"
>> Oh, hey. Well, well, well. Radar
Apologetics in the building, y'all.
Yes, sir.
>> Yeah. So, this is the IRL. So, the live
stream here's this mic.
>> What's up, live stream? Thanks so much
for tuning in.
>> Great. Apologetic.
>> Yeah, we're good.
>> Okay. So, now
>> what up, secretary?
>> All right. So, did he get the verse?
>> Me and Yeah, we done.
>> You guys are done. going to do. God lo
>> what we're going to do now is talk about
what is most important.
>> Yeah. The Islamic dilemma.
>> No.
Muhammad is a true prophet and Sadik is
going to prove it for us. Wait a minute.
Wait a minute. So if anyone can tell us
the first thing he's not a true first
listen how you see listen I want you to
look around you. I am the only Muslim
here.
>> That's right.
>> For him, y'all. He the only Muslim.
>> He is very brave. Listen to me.
>> I'm this rice and bean eating Muslim
that keeps it real for
you. Heard.
Okay. So, I'm here in defense and doing
the best I can in odds that won't allow
me in reality to express myself. So
therefore, let's do this. The crux of
the matter is this and one only.
>> Christianity is based on his
>> Hey, he said Christianity is based.
Hey, make sure you clip that. Clip it.
He didn't say nothing else.
>> Live converted live new top DA leader
gets converts to Christianity.
>> You see this? You see this is what I
mean. What What is this intended to do?
This is intended to divert to divert
what the points that I'm going to bring
up and what I want to talk about because
that is why Christianity focuses
completely and totally on programmics
against Islam to keep the pressure off
the Bible and keep pressure off
Christianity because Christianity cannot
be defended.
>> No, notice this though. Just I want to
respond to that because he he said that
that Christianity focuses on pyics
meaning arguments against Islam. But
last time I checked, does the Bible
mention Isl? Yo,
>> do do you know that the the Quran talks
about us more than it talks about
Muhammad?
>> That's crazy, isn't it?
>> So, it looks like Islam is actually a
pyic against we even think about y'all.
Can I talk about us first? Your guide
and your prophet way before we ever
heard of your father. Don't mind when we
respond. Your book calls us the worst of
creatures.
>> Do we get to respond? Your book says
that our religion is false. Do we get to
respond? They want this world where they
get to blast us, call for violence
against us, even kill us, and we just
have to sit here like good demies and
take it all. Too bad, Sadique. We are
not, have never been, and never will be
your demies.
>> Boom. Boom.
>> First of all, if you want to talk about
demies, the action of demies actually
occurred in the Bible. It begins in the
Bible in what you call tributaries in
the Bible. Where in fact in the book of
Deuteronomy, it talks about tributaries
where you are to fight. in book of
Deuteronomy where you ought to fight
people that are far off, not a threat
from you, not a threat, and subject
them. If they do not subject and allow
themselves to be tributaries, siphoning
everything that they have to you, then
they are to be put to the smear and
killed. This is called tributaries. Now,
let me and if Sadique thinks that's a
problem, yes. One second. One second.
One second. No, I'll be quick. I'll be
quick. If Sadi thinks that the book of
Deuteronomy is immoral and wicked, why
did his God and his prophet affirm it as
the inspired, preserved, authoritative
word of God that we are supposed to
judge by? You just condemned your own
fake prophet, Sadique.
>> Alhamdulillah.
He I condemned my fake prophet with your
mouth when you won't allow me to speak
and defend it. Now, that's a whole
completely different thing.
>> I'm assuming you want to be a good
Muslim. If you want to be a good Muslim,
you show me your prophet.
>> I'll do that for you.
>> Can I do that?
>> Listen. You got squashed by Daniel Haku.
The
second
Can I finish? Can I finish your point?
>> You got the mic. Can I finish a point?
The second you said that the Bible does
not confirm the Bible, you killed the
entire previs of your of the Islamic
dilemma. Now, let me go. Now, please let
me Can I please soft, please? All right.
>> Now, let me just go logic. Oh, I'm gonna
go. Let me make a let me just
>> I thought you just did.
>> No, let me just let me just let me just
unite us in one subject. Okay. Now,
>> now the subject I want to unite us in is
that
>> ignore. Ignore him. He's He's He's just
a troll.
>> Yeah. You see, you see what you have to
know about David Wood is that his life,
his freedom depends on Islam. Because
you see, if it wasn't for his, let me
finish. If it wasn't, let me finish. If
it wasn't for Islam, David Wood would
succumb to his psychosis.
>> Wow.
>> Now, let me finish. Let me finish. Let
me finish.
>> Imagine what would have happened to
Islam. Yeah. You'd have been killing
puppies. You'd have been killing ducks.
You'd have been killing puppies, baby
ducks, chickens, and and kittens.
Chickens and kittens. You'd have been
killing them. Now, let's talk about
that. Now, let's please. Now, let me
just
>> But it's not because of Islam. It's
thanks to Jesus Christ.
>> Let me just make the point. See, that's
called playing to the crowd, which is
99%
play to the crowd. No, they would never
do that.
>> No, but you did, man. You got
>> Now, listen.
>> The most important thing.
>> Yeah. The most important thing to
Christianity, call it however you want
to call it. Christianity is this offer
of salvation. Is am I right or wrong?
Did Christianity rest its existence on
the death and resurrection of Jesus? Yes
or no?
>> Yes,
>> that's true.
>> Okay. Now, I have a question. The
apostle Paul
>> in the book of in the Apostle Paul, by
the way, take a look at that. You see
light?
>> Look at my face.
>> This is called No. You're a white boy.
I'm Puerto Rican. Now look
light that's called Nord but anyway so
>> you know who else was really white
>> Muhammad
[Music]
>> yes and Muhammad had a son who remained
he married into his family and became
the general of his armies and the
descendants became the general of his
armies don't ever talk wait a minute do
not ever talk to me his adopted said now
do not ever talk to me
>> he took his wife from
>> let me tell you something.
>> He's talking about his son. Let me tell
you something.
>> It's not his son. Allah abolished
adoption so that he could bang his
adopted son's wife.
>> Very nice. Very nice. But you see that's
his take because you see David
>> verses 4 to 5 abolishes adoption in
Islam and it was to justify Muhammad
banging the wife of his own adopted son.
The sick pervert. First of all,
>> a sick pervert. The sick pervert was
Isaac. Was Isaac. But anyway, let me go
to We we we respect we respect all
prophets and all.
>> Can I finish?
>> Sure.
>> Continue.
>> The Bible and let me please I want you
all to listen to this.
>> The reason that the
>> David the reason that the Bible puts the
prophets in positions where they are not
completely perfect, where they show
their human side, do you know why? So
that God could show that his forgiveness
and mercy was before Jesus and after
him. That he forgave prophets that did
what they did and that his mercy
extended to them. And in fact those
descendants of prophets descendants of
prophets of prophets that committed
certain acts where they had children are
in the very genealogies of Jesus Christ
in the book of Matthew, book of Luke.
Now let me continue. Let me say please
David let me say this. Salvation is
extremely important. Right.
>> Right.
>> This is what you stand on. Right.
>> You what you offer for the benefit of
mankind is the offer of salvation and
forgiveness and mercy from God through
Jesus.
>> Right.
>> So I'm asking you, let's put that to the
test. Did the Apostle Paul in the book
of Hebrews chapter 10:18 who said uh
that the blood of Jesus will end blood,
sin, sacrifice forever? Is that
statement completely scripturally true?
Let me preface it by saying this. The
Apostle Paul claimed to be a sin.
>> That's not what we're talking about.
>> No, no, no. But this is what we're going
to talk about also. Listen. or else talk
about
you see let me please
>> yeah that's not what we're talking about
if if you do if you
>> you see this whole thing rest
>> I have no problem talking about that
next
>> no let's talk about this and then I'll
talk about that then
>> okay all right take care of yourself on
the way out
your head on the way out
>> your head on the way out
>> so so we have here you you came to my
event and we got topics we've been
running this topic the same way with
every Muslim. We just went to a Muslim
booth today, y'all. And they couldn't
give us a single answer on why is it
that the Quran confirms the Bible yet
contradiction. But you're here. You're
very confident. You seem very
knowledgeable. You got your notes. So
the topic hand first and then go
wherever you want. You got look, you got
my word. If you want to talk about your
subject, you have no we have no problem.
deal with the Islamic dilemma first and
then we can talk about sin sacrifices.
You can talk about You can talk about
dilemma. Wait a minute. Then I will take
you over there. We'll do a live on my
TikTok and we can go through all that.
You can talk about dilemma all you want.
It's your dilemma.
>> Wait a minute. But if you don't have
foundation where you're legit where
you're legitimate, then you got to shut
your mouth.
>> Hallelujah. Hallelujah. Hallelujah. Wait
a minute. Good. That's good. Our Muslim
friends have no foundation for what they
believe and the foundation of
themselves.
Our scripture contradicts it. Islam has
no foundation and not according to me.
I'm happy to let people speak but Sadik
says that Muslims need to shut their
mouths
not in the Old Testament. The dual
nature. In fact, when Jesus came and
spent 40 days, let me ask you, did he
teach the the disciples the ins and outs
and the mechanics of dual nature? Yes or
no?
>> Did the did the Quran?
>> No, I'm asking the Bible against God and
his prophets.
>> Would you answer the question? You can't
answer a question.
>> Yeah, we can. Did the Quran affirm that?
>> Did the Does the Quran affirm what?
>> The gospel that Jesus whatever he taught
in the gospel that we read in Matthew
when he's going over with his disciples,
does the Quran confirm that?
>> No. So then what does it say? Now let me
tell you now will you allow me to talk
what is it confir?
>> Okay. You're too pretty for that. Now
listen
on tell you. But anyway testing testing.
But anyway
let me give you and I'm going to be
brief on this. The Quran from the very
beginning establishes because we in
Islam are completely entire. This is why
we stick to certain hadith and certain
sayings like for instance that in a
hadith it says that God has you want to
say two right arms, two left heads and
two we stick to it. We stick to it
because if it is written by God and it's
there in scripture then the Muslim says
we take it for what it says and we don't
interpret it. We leave it at that. We
leave it at that.
>> I love it. Then your book says affirm it
affirms our book, our gospel, our our
Torah and it orders us. And if you don't
interpret it, then go with what it says.
That's the Islamic dilemma. How are you
not getting this?
>> Can I finish?
>> So then the Quran, you see, this is what
he must do. And this is what you are all
about here now. Not to allow an answer
to flow, a thought to give you the full
answer. But how is it when every single
time I try to make a point?
>> Okay. All right. Let me let me shut him
down. Hey, David. Now let me
>> chill out.
>> Okay. Now let me ask now let me ask you
on Islamic dilemma. This is what you
want. Now
>> yeah that's what I want.
>> Okay. Now so the Quran then affirms
because this is the righteousness of
Allah and the truth of Allah that he is
the one who inspired scripture and
revelation to mankind. That's part of
his mercy. And he affirms therefore that
he inspired and generated the Bible, the
Torah and the or what you would call the
New Testament that this that he inspired
it and he does not deny the Quran. In
fact, the Quran mentions more talks
about other prophets more than it does
the prophet Muhammad and more about
other things because it's not a book
dedicated to selling,
>> you know, itself like the Bible is
dedicated to selling Judaism.
It is a book a guidance for all of
mankind free of that type of pro of that
type of aspect. Okay. Now, so the Quran
affirms this and it says that, okay, let
me finish that. The Bible was indeed
revealed and inspired by God without a
shadow of a doubt.
>> But then what happens is but then what
happens is what is held in esteem is the
law. The halapa
>> the how you say it
>> the law by the the law because that is
eternal in Islam is the Sharia. Now the
law is extremely important because that
is the means by which society culture is
defined and by the way it moves together
and evolves. So law is extremely
important. So the Quran then verifies
the law that was given. Now look what
the Quran does. Can I let me finish this
part right here.
>> You say you come on bro.
>> Let me just finish this point right
here.
>> All right. I'll let you wrap this up.
>> Okay. The point right here is then after
that
>> the Quran then takes on the obligation
as it says in the Quran. This is the
scripture that has come to protect the
truth that which came before it. So then
the the Quran takes a line item approach
to the theological claims of the Bible.
This is why David Let me ask you where
does the Quran confirm that Jesus Christ
is the son of God who has a Greek assay
to God who is eternally generated with
God who has wait a minute who has God's
essence and nature that where does God
affirm that son and that he is going to
die for our sins on the third day
>> can we answer that yeah
>> yeah sure 2 chapter 2 41 it says believe
in what we have revealed
>> confirming what is with you So what is
with them? Now guys, did you guys hear
his question? Question was where does
the Quran confirm this this concept of a
a son of God who is equal in nature with
the father and so on and so forth.
Right? So when it says that the Quran
confirms that which is with them in
possession of the Jews and Christians,
what was with them? IP
>> the gospel.
>> The gospel. And in the gospel it says
for God so loved the world that he gave
his only son that whoever believes in
him should not perish but have
everlasting life. It also says in the
gospel, look, you went on perfect on
time. It also says in the gospel in John
6:40, that whoever, this is the will of
my father that all who look on the son
and believes in him will have eternal
life and I will raise him up on the last
day. Here's another one in the gospel.
It says that before times the has
revealed himself and spoken by many
prophets. I need Hey, I need you to pay
attention. Pay attention.
>> I know those. Okay, good. But I'm just
identify.
>> Did I let him Did I let him tie? Did I
>> Did I let him talk? Did I interrupt him?
I I even I even I even put David on the
leash for you.
>> I even put David on the leash for you.
>> I let him talk for 3 minutes straight.
We waited for an answer and we didn't
get an answer.
>> So So here it is. So I gave gave you I
gave you what the gospel says about the
divine son. And so now your Quran
confirms what was with them of the
gospel. So that's where your Quran
confirms that. Okay. No, there real
quick.
>> Yo, this dude right here was over there
debating some Hebrew Israelites
>> and this dude had them stuck. Do you
hear me?
>> Had them stuck. So I just want to give a
shout out, give you your flowers, man.
Praise God for you. And uh where can
people find your content and your and
you know just give them your
information.
>> Uh Instagram is un_l
l y a r e d and then YouTube and Tik Tok
it's soldier for Christ. Soldier number
four Christ. So
>> for the glory of God man. Thank you.
>> That's right. That's right.
>> You know what?
>> We got we got these soldiers rising up
guys. So it's really amazing.
>> A victim.
>> By the way um
>> a victim. You heard.
>> Now let me tell you something.
>> Wait. So here we are. We got we got to
come back to it. We got to come back to
I'm going to give you the mic, too. You
gave five verses.
>> Yeah, I know. I gave you. So, what what
we did was what I showed you was is that
in the gospel, it says that God has a
divine son that he sent to the world.
Your Quran confirms the gospel. So, you
asked, "Where does the Quran confirm
that God has a son?" When he confirmed
the gospel.
>> Okay. Now, can I say something?
>> Yeah. Absolutely.
>> First of all, and I hope you let me
finish. I said where in the Bible in the
gospel does it say in specific terms
remember this is what you base your
religion on that God sent a son who is
equal in nature equal in essence with
the same asy who is eternally generated
who is completely co-equal to God
>> where did he send no that's not an
answer because he named nobody in fact
none of the verses say Jesus now let me
take this to to another point
the Quran deals deals with that. For
instance, alhamdulillah,
the Quran deals with that in surah 19
was the sunship of Jesus in surah surah
19 verse 75 to 89. It puts it in terms
of the sunship of Jesus Christ in a
manner that has never been put in any
scripture in human history. It says the
earth shakes, the mountain is const
the earth shakes, the mountain tumbles
at the aspect that God would take on the
sun most most majestic. Now what I'm
saying and let me finish the point is
why we're dealing with this point.
>> So the Quran talk a little louder.
>> Yeah. Flip it around.
>> Okay. Here you are.
>> Okay,
>> baby. Baby,
>> there you go.
>> You don't understand
how much I love you, baby. Yeah. Here we
go.
>> You heard that? I showed you who I was.
>> But who I was is not who I am. I sing
now in my heart for Allah subhana wa
tala for
>> That's wrong, man.
>> No, no, but I'm singing. You're making
it singing in that way.
>> You got a good voice, but that's a wrong
man. But, but ain't I? Yo, listen.
>> Ain't that wasn't that the bomb? But
anyway, um, so the Quran then takes a
line item approach while establishing
yes that the both the gospel and the
Quran was revealed by God. Of course,
he's going to say that this is the the
same way the Quran has the how can I say
it? I'm not going to say it, but has the
gumption to call Christians and Jews the
people of the book. But anyway, so the
Quran does that because of the statement
of truth and its commitment to truth. It
does not deny you who you are as people
who received revelation from God.
>> Man, quit preaching, man.
>> Can I respond to this real quick?
>> Okay. No, let me finish because the
point
>> All right, you got you got to land wrap
this up though, dude. I'm going to wrap
it up.
>> Let's not trade monologues. Let's have a
conversation.
>> I'm going to wrap it up.
>> So, the Quran then takes a line item
approach and rejects those basic
theological uh claims by Christianity on
a line item basis and rejects them
directly while confirming that that
book. Now, let me ask you a question.
Was the Bible, the Old Testament, and
the New Testament in the seventh
century? Was it the original text? Did
the Jews and Christians have the
original gospel and the original Torah
in the seventh century? Yes or no?
>> According to your Quran, yes. Because
according to your Quran, it says that it
confirms the Torah and the Gospel.
Notice how I let you talk, right?
>> No. But that's
>> Come on. Notice how I let you talk.
Look, you don't got to be panicking so
early. No. Muslims.
>> Why you panicking so early, man? Trying
to jump out the pot. Because we Muslims
say you don't have the original.
>> Hey, and but Allah says I do. But we
know you don't have the original Quran.
We know it's been changed. Come on, man.
Let me let me talk.
>> Say what you want. Okay.
>> Let me talk. Can I talk? But I want to
talk to you though. I don't want to talk
at you.
>> Okay. But do not distort what I said.
>> I didn't say what you said.
>> Look, look, look. You said you asked me.
I can repeat your question. You asked
me, did the Jews and the Christians in
the 7th century have the original Torah
and gospel that Allah originally
revealed to the prophets? That was your
question, right? My answer yes. So my
answer to you
my answer to you is yes according to
your Quran. Your Quran does not make a
distinction. Let me I'll let I'll let
I'll let you notice this.
>> I let him talk three minutes straight.
No interruptions yet. I I'm now to
answer his question. He's immediately
interrupting me. If you want to have a
dollar, look,
>> if you want to deal with that directly
before you run,
>> I have no problem. If you want if you
want to do it like this, let's do it
like this. But let's not trade three
minute monologue. Is that what you want
to do?
>> Okay, let's go further.
>> Okay, let's go point for point. If you
want to inter if you want to interact
like that.
>> Okay, cool. So, according I I'll stop
here. Your Quran says that is confirming
the Torah and Gospel that's there in the
seventh century. It makes no distinction
between what they had in the seventh
century in Muhammad's time and what they
had in Moses and Jesus's time. Okay?
Islamic scholarship in totality. Now
listen, don't talk throw away
scholarship because you consult
scholarship all the time. In fact, you
make it a point to quote hadiths on a
regular basis. On a regular basis. But
the hadiths are only good when they suit
your purpose.
>> That's right. Now when the now in your
mind because you have a degree in the
science of hadith
>> no okay in my heart. So in your mind, so
when they when they said you now the
Quran, look what it does. Again, I'll
repeat the Quran takes a line. I it
confirms that the gospel that's what you
had. Did you had this revelation that
was given to you as Christians? It was
there. The Quran confirms it. It was
there. That gospel that you had, you
know, that you call supposedly the
gospels. By the way, this is a gospel.
What gospel you have? This is a side
point.
>> Do we have that?
>> Okay, let let me finish. And this is a
side point. the gospel that you had with
you at that time, seventh century, but
the Quran.
>> Wait, I'm sorry. I misunderstood you.
I'm answer.
>> No, just cl just clarify.
>> You said that I can finish.
>> No, no. I said I said we can interact
with each other's points cuz that's what
you wanted to do.
>> Finished the point first. You made three
already.
>> No, I didn't. You made it. Now,
>> Jesus, Lord Almighty.
>> So, the Quran then
>> now you made me forget. So the Quran So
the Quran So the Quran deals with that
what you had in your hands and then what
you had confirms what you had in your
hands because that's the only thing you
got in your hands and then takes a line
item approach the to its theological
content.
>> Okay. So where does it do that? Where
where does this where does it say that?
Yeah. Where does it say in the Quran?
Look this is what I want. Where does it
say in the Quran that what I have in my
scriptures that it's addressing what is
in my scriptures and that it's saying
that what's in my scriptures about Jesus
being the son, Jesus being crucified or
being God that this is wrong. It's in
the scriptures, not what they say, but
that it's in my books.
>> Okay, this is Islamic scholarship and
it's and it's talked to talked about in
the Quran. Islamic scholarship itself,
let me finish the verse. I need the
verse.
>> Let me finish. Let me finish. Let me
finish.
>> Is the assayity
>> Oh my god. of the son of God in the Old
Testament.
>> Give us the verse. Give us the verse.
Give us the verse. Give us the verse.
Give us the verse.
>> You rely on the interpret. Let me ask
you what what do you think about the
church fathers?
>> I don't care about that, bro.
I'm not I'm not going to deal with that.
What?
>> I'm not going to deal with that.
>> Well, she's asking first. I tell you
what, get yourself Get yourself a life.
Get yourself a life.
>> Get the Get the
Get the Get the Get the
>> Just listen. We just want the verse.
>> Okay. You see, I would I would tell you,
sister, get yourself a life. Cover
yourself. Stop.
>> Now, second.
>> All right. All right. And and stop doing
this. Don't call your sister like that.
Please, no, no distra don't don't use
that as a distraction. Look, look, we'll
ask it again cuz he's just using this as
a distraction. Here it is again. Where
in the Quran I'll ask the question again
so you can get the chance to answer.
Where in the Quran does it address my
book and says that what my book says is
false addresses particular points in my
book and says this is false. Okay.
>> Woe to those who write the book with
their own hands to profit for music for
Christ. Woe for what they say and woe
for what they earn. This is addressing
that that which you have in your hands
is a product of what? In fact, it's a
product of both
and alif
both of them. Now, who said this? I have
a video. If you please people go to my
Tik Tok sadik.
>> I like that plug, man. No, because let
let me finish so that you can get
details on this subject. Go to Sadika
del Malik, the fate of faith on Tik Tok.
Go to it right now. 18.
>> I'm not going to follow you. We're not
going to follow you. Please.
>> Don't follow me. Let me tell you this.
Don't let them use you as a distraction.
Just focus. Just focus. Just focus.
>> Focus. Hey. Hey guys, follow him on Tik
Tok.
>> Yeah. We need Sadi. We need you on the
camera. Sadique. We need you. We need
you on the camera.
Yeah. He's using you as a distraction
like that.
>> Come on. No distraction.
>> That's what you want.
>> Focus. Focus. Sad. Sad.
You got to focus, man.
>> Right here.
>> So anyway, so anyway, now they make me
forget the points.
>> What you're saying is that woe to those
who who write them hands.
>> So this is an indication that the Quran
is doubting that which you have in your
hands at that time. Then therefore,
let me finish. Can I finish?
>> I can prove 100% that's a lie. Just let
me go. Quick one, quick one, quick one,
quick one. No, no, no, no. And then
you'll think of that. This is why the
Quran takes a line item approach to your
content, fool. You hear me say, oh boy,
listen. I'm going get I'm going to get
you a baby duck for you to kill. So
anyway,
>> let me tell you why. You know why? This
man doesn't realize that his sanity.
Now listen. So the Quran's doubting what
we have in our hands. 42 years
>> every day.
>> If it wasn't for Islam, he wouldn't be
the one who is right now. But anyway,
>> and by the way, why do you follow a
sociopath,
>> brother? Can you get to the point?
>> Okay, same thing for you. Why do you
follow sociopath? Didn't you learn what
didn't you learn with Adolf Hitler? If
you don't learn,
>> I don't follow a sociopath. You know who
I follow? I follow Jesus who's right
here living in this man's heart. But but
that Jesus
>> and that Jesus changed him into a
glorious son of God through his own
blood by washing him clean. It's not who
he was. It's who he is now. He died to
himself. He died to himself and now
through Jesus shines through him. That's
who we fall. Stay there. Stay there.
Please state it.
>> So So you wait just real quick.
>> Please state that. I want you to stay.
>> 279 in the Quran. He says, "Woe to those
who write the book with their own hands,
claiming it's from God, seeking a small
price." So, he says that this verse is
what demonstrates that the Quran doubts
what is in the possession of the Jews
and Christians. Now, David says that he
can prove that that's a lie. All right.
So, David, what you got for us?
>> Well, this not going to be hard, ladies
and gentlemen. Uh, there's this thing
called context. Read the verses before,
read the verses that come after. You go
to Surah 2. You already quoted one. You
go to surah 2:es 40 to 44 where Allah
says that the reason the people of the
book should believe in Muhammad and the
Quran is because they're affirming the
scriptures that are with us which Sadi
keeps attacking and saying are
corrupted. Then you get to verse 79 that
says woe to those who write the book
with their own hands. And he says that's
talking about our book being corrupted.
What he doesn't tell you is that just
six verses later, surah 2 verse 85,
Allah says to the people of the book,
"Do you only believe in part of your
book and not in all of it?"
>> If you don't believe in all of it, every
last verse, he says he will send us to
hell.
>> So he's he's lying about his own god.
He's lying about his own book. He's
lying about his own prophet. So the
question is, what is surah 2:79 actually
talking about? It's talking about
writing something in addition to the
scriptures and treating that as if it's
the word of God. We're quoting the Torah
and the gospel. Allah says if you quote
something outside of it and treat it as
if it's the word of Allah, he will then
you are doomed. He says woe to you. What
does Sadi say when we challenge him?
What does he say when we challenge him
on what the Quran says? Go to the
scholars. What's that mean? He's quoting
other books and treating them as the
word of Allah. And Allah says woe to
you. Okay. Now, now
where does the word trinity is not
listen?
[Applause]
>> Even if you're right, Sadik,
>> that's what I'm trying to say. You're
talking about Islamic scholars. Even if
you're right, if you're right, if 279 is
about the corruption of the scriptures,
it just means the Quran is hopelessly
contradictory cuz it says our scriptures
are corrupted, but we're to judge by
them. We're to stand on them. It's
confirming them. It makes no sense if
you're right.
>> It's two against one. It confirms, as I
told you, the Quran, if you read it,
takes a line item line item approach to
the most. You see chapter verse you see
chapter in verse one verse one is it too
much
>> okay can I for one
>> you see you won't let me talk what
you're doing
>> you see this is not communication
>> what is caused no
is this the way you do it
>> you're contradicting your is this how
you do it your god says you're going
>> is this how you do it God and your
prophet say you're going
>> well you don't allow because of the
power of the truth you won't allow it to
be spoken
>> you're not talking truth Look, man,
you're wasting a lot of time.
>> The Quran again, where does the Quran
affirm father, son, and holy ghost?
>> When it says that it affirms the gospel.
>> No, because again, it's not citing. The
Quran says not trinity.
>> Okay, I got say not very good. Let me
finish.
>> That's the dilemma. Got it. He gets it.
>> No. No. Listen.
>> So, here's the problem.
>> No, listen. Quran says don't say trinity
but it affirms a book that claims the
trinity
listen
>> the Quran is telling you directly to
stay away from I told you it's a line
item approach to the theological claims
of the Bible now that's what I'm saying
yeah we already had a verse
I'm not
>> get the verse another one but Would you?
>> All right. Look, so
>> Jesus is nothing but a prophet. Not the
son of God. He is not God. The Quran
told you that he is not God.
>> The problem that we're having here,
Sadi, listen. Let me
>> The problem that we're having, just hear
me out, my brother.
>> The problem that we're having is that
you are affirming the Islamic dilemma.
>> No, it's not.
>> You're you're you're proving to us. Look
guys, pay attention. Here's the
argument. Everybody paying attention.
Here's the argument. The argument is the
Quran says that to not say trinity. The
Quran says that God has no son. Okay.
So, it's saying that your book, Avery,
is false. Christians, your book is
false. No, it's not. Okay, I'll grant
you that. But otherwise,
>> it's taking a line item of
>> But it also says,
it also says, "Let the people of the
gospel judge by what God revealed in
it." It says, "If those who do not
follow the gospel, you are rebellious."
So at the same time, the Quran is
affirming a book that it's contradicting
at the same time. Don't deny me. So he
has no self-awareness that he's
affirming the Islamic dilemma. You're
proving our point.
>> Now, let me say something.
>> Did you hear what I said?
>> I I heard N. You know what? You know I
You know what I
>> You were yelling when I was talking,
man.
>> You know, because I'm talking to him and
making the point now.
>> But you're trying to make a point when I
make a point.
>> I'll stress it over and over again. The
Quran, the Quran does not deny that the
Bible was revealed by God, the only New
Testament.
>> Amen.
>> But then it takes the approach because
the Quran says this is
>> and that's it.
>> I get his argument. I get his argument.
Here's what he's saying.
>> He's saying look look in the Old
Testament
saying
bothering me.
>> Focus focus this way. Let her get her
and you're saying there's no right.
You're saying there's no asy in the Old
Testament.
>> I mean, she got her hips broken. You
heard?
>> Your argument is in the Old Testament
there's no asy. So like we can go to
scholars that will help us to find and
understand these verses to understand
Christian doctrine. Like a say this
doesn't work. The reason it doesn't work
is because we don't have verses in the
Bible where it says that we cannot go to
scholars because we're not make that
without making partners with Allah. So
that doesn't work. Your Quran says this
thing that you cannot go to your your
your rabbis, your priests in sewer nine.
You cannot worship them. What is
Muhammad when he says that? He says
that. So that's the problem. You're
assuming. No, you're assuming Islamic
standards on Christian doctrines. That's
not how this works. Your books, your
books say certain things, give you
certain parameters to live by, to do
certain things by those parameters are
not on the Bible, and you're trying to
force them on us. That's the problem. He
just He just have to focus. Focus here.
Focus here.
>> Now listen, can you see me? Because I
don't want any of these beautiful people
to understand and not know what a
75year-old man who eats rice and beans
looks like. But anyway, so let's get to
the point now. We dealt with this thing
on I gave you my point over and over
again and you have
>> we didn't deal with it. You didn't you
didn't deal with nothing.
>> How many times did I say nine item
approach? How many times did I say that
the Quran deal with the Bible affirms
that it was revealed? Now let me ask you
a question. Is what I have is what is is
what I have what Allah revealed
>> is what the the books that I have in my
possession right now do I have what
Allah revealed
>> parts of it are what Allah revealed
that's why
can I finish
that's why it takes a line item approach
now let me please let me finish the
statement now I want you to answer this
question no show us where the Quran says
that please I already gave you a verse I
already gave you the verse and and gave
it put Which person is supposedly
refusing sitting alone? I need you. I
can't do it.
>> I need you to understand what I'm
saying. Okay, cuz I understand what
you're saying. I know you are, but
you're you're yelling over us. That's
why. Look, I hear you. You got three
people and I'm one. I'm yelling over
you.
>> Yes, you're yelling over me. We letting
you talk, man. So, look, here it is.
Look, brother, just have the patience.
See, when you're Christian
and you have the Holy Spirit to be able
to listen to you so we can we can hear
you out. So the point is Sadik,
>> we get your argument. What we're asking
you to do, you're saying that the Quran
gives a line by line, basically a a
criticism of what is in the scriptures,
right? That it's is it agrees with some
parts and then it tells us the parts it
disagrees with, right?
>> Yeah. What I need you to do besides give
me a beat that's super dumping.
>> What I need you to do is give me a verse
where the Quran is saying this is in the
scripture and this is what we disagree
with as Allah.
>> Okay.
>> Now you want the Quran. Does the Quran
confirm what your own Bible does not
confirm? Does the Quran confirm Trinity?
Father, Son, and Holy Ghost
>> when it affirms the gospel. Yes. But it
also contradicts it by
>> let me ask you something. Let me ask you
something. Is that gospel that you say
is confirms the gospel? Is it confirmed
also by the Torah?
>> He said he said
>> okay let me finish. Let me
>> according to he said where in the Torah
the gospel uh is confirmed by the Torah.
>> No no that's not what I said. That's
exactly I said where does the Torah
confirm trinity? Father, son, and holy
ghost. Now you're switching it. Now
you're switching. Father, are you
recording it? Did you Wait a minute. Did
you record it? Hey, when does the Torah
confirm the Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit? I got you. You got Deuteronomy
32:6. It says, "Is he not your father
who created you?" You got in Isaiah 9:6.
It says, "For unto us a child is born, a
son is given, and his name shall be
called the mighty God." There we go. We
got 2 Samuel 23:es 2-3. It says, "The
spirit of Yahweh speaks by me." The God
God's words are on my tongue. So we got
the Father, the Son, the Holy Spirit all
in the Old Testament. There you go. Let
me give you one more verse here. Hey,
you will like this one. In chapter 5,
46, y'all. It says, "And we gave Jesus
the gospel, confirming the Torah which
came before it." So in your book and my
book, it confirms what I got. Is that
the truth?
>> Again, is it the truth?
>> Okay. The truth.
>> Is the truth.
be alive. Let me
>> You never let me ask you and you saying
it alive.
>> Is Isaiah 9:6 in the Old Testament in
your How's it written?
Benu
in Hebrew, baby.
>> In Hebrew, I'm sorry. It's okay. Okay.
In Hebrew, I'm giving you the original
verse. What did they do? They took the
verbs in the verse which is byra and the
other verse and they changed the verbs
to a future tense. Change it from the
Hebrew perfect tense. The perfect tense
is past. They call it perfect tense
because it's proven. It already
happened. So past tense in Hebrew
grammar is not past tense but the
perfect tense. Now let me finish. Should
I pour?
>> Okay. Now, now, so now, now let's
answer cuz none of that was false.
>> All of that was false. Wait a minute.
Let me finish.
>> How does that answer
that says that these scriptures are
false points?
>> What you pointed out is not confirmed in
the Old Testament. That's why 99.9%
of all Jews reject Christianity. Why
99.9%
of all Jews rejected Jesus in his time.
And why that is false? The histo the
sociologist and historian Rodney Stark
actually points out many Jews converted
to Christianity early on. They just they
just did not keep their Jewishness. Yes.
Triumphal Christianity. Yes. Yes.
Answer.
>> Yes. Let me answer. Many
>> Jesus could not get enough people to
scream for his release and from Pontious
Pilot.
>> Are you kidding me?
>> Do you think all the Jews of the first
century were at Jesus a child?
I'm not talking about I'm talking about
the Christian listen the Christian let
me finish a point if not I'm talking
about the Christian interpolated but
notice how you left how the Quran is
confirming what we have
>> we have we have a Jew here we have we
have a
>> what's up brother
Jew
>> this is radar listen listen this is
radar
>> oh he's not a Jew cuz he
>> this is radar apologetics he is a
messianic Jew. He believes in Jesus.
Okay.
>> All right. All right. All right. All
right. So, let's look at the text real
quick. Brother,
go ahead. You ready?
Aad shalom. Check it out. What will be
his name? Pellegore.
Mighty God. You know what's so crazy?
How does Isaiah use mighty God Elgabore?
In chapter 10, he refers to the God of
Israel as mighty God.
>> Elgibore
is used for mighty and strong man.
>> No, no, no. Check it out. What does
Listen, is Eli Ball used for mighty and
strong man? Why? Okay. Because you have
a microphone and I don't.
>> Okay. Now, is Elie Ball used for mighty
and strong man? Yes or no?
>> What verse you use it for? What verse
you want to go to? What verse you want
to go to? It used Elgibore. Is it used
also for a mighty and strong man also?
You got a verse.
>> Pull it up. Pull it up. Get that.
>> You're the Jew.
>> Get the verse.
>> Wait a minute. You're the Jew.
>> My verse is right here. What Isaiah
believes the child to be born from
Isaiah 7. It's a sign from God. That's
why it's a virgin. That's why it's
Emmanuel, God with us. In Isaiah 9, he's
called mighty God. In Isaiah 10, this is
the God of Israel referred to. This is
what Isaiah believes. Now, can we talk?
>> And hold on, one more thing. Let me
throw one more thing at you. And you got
the mic.
>> This is Listen, hold on. Hold on. Let me
throw the statue real quick.
>> Against one.
>> It's all right.
>> I want you to see this.
>> Listen. Check this out real quick. Real
quick.
>> Against one. When I make
>> He's right. It is four against one
because the Uma did not show up. Where
is the Uma?
>> You know why?
>> Where are they? You know why? You know
why? You know why? Because we only one
and
>> we invited the DA guys who live in New
York City popular in New York City. None
of them wanted to come. They do da when
we're not here, but when we show up,
ain't no dawa to be found to play. And
they left our friend here, Sadi, 75
years old, standing on his own, right,
against poor Christian by himself.
You take a naked.